BREAK IN.
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
>> Sean: WE CONTINUE THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
IN THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT, THE
DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA MOB
HYSTERICALLY, BREATHLESSLY,
RUNNING WITH ONE FAKE STORY
AFTER ANOTHER.
PUSHING A FALSE NARRATIVE, PER
PSI THEORIES ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
WE HAVE FOUR INVESTIGATIONS NOW
INCLUDING THE MUELLER REPORT
THAT CONCLUDES IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BUT IT WENT ON FOR TWO LONG
SOLID YEARS PLUS.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> WE'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT IF
THE NEW PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY
IS GOING TO DO WHAT RUSSIA
WANTS.
>> AS IF THERE ARE NO SHOES ON
THE TRUMP HUMAN CENTIPEDE THAT
ARE NOT ABOUT RUSSIA.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> THIS CLOUD ABOUT COLLUSION OF
RUSSIA WILL HANG OVER HIM NO
MATTER WHERE HE STANDS.
THEY'RE SHOCKED THE NOOSE IS
TIGHTENING.
>> MUELLER IS CONNECTING THE
DOTS BETWEEN A MASSIVE
INSTRUCTION INTENDED TO HIDE THE
TRUTH.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S DONE.
HE'S DONE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> HE'S GOT TO KNOW HIS FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S BEHIND BARS.
>> WE HAVE A TREASONOUS
PRESIDENT.
>> WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHO WITTINGLY OR UNWITTINGLY HAS
BEEN COMPROMISED.
>> THE PRESIDENCY IS EFFECTIVELY
A RUSSIAN O'
A RUSSIAN OP.
>> Sean: IT'S SICK.
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS, THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA REPORTED OUTRIGHT
FALSEHOODS.
>> THEY GET THE PHONE RECORDS,
THEY SEE THE CALLS TO THE
BLOCKED NUMBER AND THERE'S GOOD
EVIDENCE THAT THAT WAS PROBABLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE BEGIN THE NEW REPORT, PAUL
MANAFORT, THE CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
PAID SECRET VISITS, MULTIPLE
ONES, TO JULIANNE ASANG AT THE
ECUADORIAN EMBASSY IN LONDON.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE
GUARDIAN.
[BUZZ E
[BUZZER).
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DIRECTED HIS
ATTORNEY TO LIE TO CONGRESS.
[BUZZER]
>> Sean: SO IT'S NOTHING MORE
THAN AN EXTENSION, A BRANCH OF
ALL THINGS RADICAL, EXTREME,
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY AS
THEYING CO-NOW EVERY SINGLE
TALKING POINT OF THAT PARTY.
MARK WRITES ABOUT IN HIS BOOK,
THE MEDIA RECENTLY ECHOED THIS
DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINT THERE
WAS A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS OVER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
STANDING UP TO HOUSE COMMITTEE
SUBPOENAS.
AND THE MEDIA?
THEY REPEATED IT NEARLY 400
TIMES.
THEY TALK AND SPEAK IN UNISON.
LISTEN.
>> SO PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PURSUING A STONE WALL STRATEGY
WHEN IT COMES TO CONGRESS.
ACCORDING TO CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS, BUT THE HONEY BADGER
PRESIDENT JUST DOESN'T CARE.
>> WE'RE APPROACHING A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> WE'RE HOVERING ON A
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARS TO BE
HEADED TO A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
>> AMERICA IS DANGEROUSLY CLOSE
TO A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> MARK LEVINE'S BOOK,
"UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS," I CALL
HIM THE GREAT ONE.
BEFORE I GET TO THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION STUFF, I WANT TO GO
BACK, 5:15, ELECTION NIGHT,
2016, I TALKED TO YOU.
I ALSO TALKED TO DONALD TRUMP.
I SAID SOMEBODY IS DRAWING
STRAWS RIGHT NOW AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BRING YOU IN NEWS IS
HORRIBLE.
YOU DEPARTMENT WIN A SINGLE
STATE BASICALLY.
EXIT POLLS WERE WRONG IN '04,
THEY WERE WRONG RECENTLY IN
ISRAEL.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHEN THE
MEDIA COVERAGE STARTED ON
ELECTION NIGHT, THEY WERE
GIDDY-YAP.
YOU COULD SEE IT.
THEY HAD IT IN THE BAG.
HILLARY WON.
THEY BEAT TRUMP.
THE NIGHT PROGRESSED.
YOU COULD SEE A VISIBLE SHIFT IN
MOOD TO NEARLY GOING OFF OF THE
LEDGE.
DOES THAT NOT PROVE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN THIS BOOK?
>> DO YOUR MONTAGES NOT PROVE
IT?
>> Sean: EXACTLY.
>> GROUPTHINK, IT'S A PACK
MENTALITY.
IT'S IDEOLOGY GOING IN ONE
DIRECTION.
YOU CAN'T FIND A DIME'S WORTH OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY THIS COUNTRY.
LOOK AT THE GUESTS -- ONE OF THE
GREAT PROBLEMS -- 1942, THERE
WAS A COMMISSION WHERE THE MEDIA
LOOKED AT THE MEDIA.
THE MEDIA NEVER LOOKED AT THE
MEDIA TODAY.
>> Sean: THIS IS IN THE BOOK.
>> IT'S ALL IN THE BOOK.
WHAT THEY SAID IS THEY GAVE A
BLARING ALARM AND SAID ONE OF
THE GREAT FEARS WE HAVE IS THE
MIXTURE OF OPINION WITH NEWS.
I POINT OUT, THERE'S A STUDY AT
HARVARD, NOT RIGHT WING, NOT
LEFT WING, IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THEY STUDY THE MEDIA.
YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST 100 DAYS
OF THE COVERAGE OF DONALD TRUMP.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY FOUND?
90% OF THE COVERAGE WAS NEGATIVE
ON CNN AND NBC.
OVER 80%, "NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST," NOBODY WAS
BELOW THE MID 70% RANGE EXCEPT
FOX.
IT WAS 52-48% NEGATIVE-POSITIVE.
ABOUT AS EVEN HANDED AS YOU CAN
GET ON THE NEWS SIDE.
THERE'S NO DISTINCTION BETWEEN
NEWS AND OPINION ON THE OTHER
NETWORKS.
IT'S HARD TO FIND DISTINCTION
BETWEEN NEWS AND OPINION IN THE
FRONT PAGES OF "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE "WASHINGTON
POST."
I'LL GIVE YOU A FEW MORE
EXAMPLES.
>> YOU QUOTED, I THINK IT WAS A
POLITICAL ARTICLE IN THE BOOK.
FIRST TIME THEY TALKED ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT WAS APRIL OF 2016.
>> THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT --
>> >> Sean: YEAH, HOW MANY
MONTHS OUT OF THE ELECTION.
>> THEY'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT SINCE HE WAS A
CANDIDATE.
THIS IDEA OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS, I SPENT MY LIFE WORKING
ON THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS IN
CONGRESS WHO HAVE NO
COMPREHENSION OF WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO THEY GET A LOT OF AIR TIME ON
MSNBC AND CNN.
THEY GET A LOT OF -- THEY GET A
LOT OF TIME ON THE PAGES OF "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" JUST BECAUSE
CONGRESS ISSUES DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF SUBPOENAS DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE SUBPOENAS ARE
LEGITIMATE.
AND IN THIS CASE, THEY'RE
INTENTIONALLY ILLEGITIMATE.
THEY'RE ALL PERSONAL.
THEY'RE ALL AIMED AT CITIZEN
TRUMP.
THEY'RE ALL VIOLATIONS OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS AN OBLIGATION, NOT
JUST FOR HIMSELF, BUT TO PROTECT
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY AND
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
IT IS MR. NADLER WHO'S THE
DICTATOR.
MR. SHIFT WHO ARE THE DICTATORS,
THEY'RE THE DEMAGOGUES ALL OVER
TV.
THESE ARE NOT OBJECTIVE
INDIVIDUALS OR PEOPLE LOOKING
FOR THE TRUTH.
THEY DON'T CARE -- IF THEY CARED
ABOUT HOW THE IRS HANDLED
PRESIDENTIAL TAX RETURNS, WHY
DIDN'T THEY CARE ABOUT IT WHEN
BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: HOW CAN THEY AS
LAWMAKERS TALK ABOUT THE
SERGEANT OF ARMS PUTTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES BRINGING -- PUTTING HIM
IN HANDCUFFS, BRINGING HIM OVER
TO THE COMMITTEE, WHEN ALL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS SAYING IS I
WILL NOT BREAK THE LAW.
YOU'RE THE ONE -- THEY'RE THE
LAWMAKERS.
>> IF IT GETS TO THAT POINT, LET
ME REMIND THESE TOUGH GUYS IN
THE HOUSE.
WHEN I LOOK AT NADLER, I THINK
TOUGH GUY, DON'T YOU?
I LOOK AT SHIFT, I THINK -- HE'S
THE GUY KICKING IT ALL OVER THE
SOCCER FIELD.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, LET ME SUGGEST
TO THE HOUSE, STOP THE STUPID
COMMENTS, I SUGGEST TO YOU THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS A LOT
MORE MANPOWER AND FIREPOWER THAN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
SO WE GO THROUGH THIS TWO-YEAR
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
WE'VE NOW HAD A NINE-MONTH FBI
INVESTIGATION, NO COLLUSION.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE, NO
COLLUSION.
NO CONSPIRACY.
WE WENT THROUGH THE BIPARTISAN
SENATE COMMITTEE, NOW THE
MUELLER REPORT, THE SAME THING.
AND THEY WANT TO KEEP GOING.
AND MY QUESTION TO YOU IS 99.9%
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA WENT
WITH THE HOAX, THE CONSPIRACY
THEORY, THE LYING, AND A
NARRATIVE THAT WAS BASED ON
FALSE INFORMATION.
OKAY?
THERE WERE A FEW OF US.
YOU'RE A PART OF THIS GROUP THAT
MAYBE 25 IN THE COUNTRY.
WE DID IT ON MY RADIO AND TV
SHOW.
YOU DID IT ON YOURS.
RUSH DID IT ON HIS.
GREG JARRETT, SARA CARTER, I
CAN'T NAME EVERYBODY.
THE POINT IS THIS, THEY GOT IT
WRONG.
HILLARY'S INVESTIGATION WAS
RIGGED.
THEY DIDN'T REPORT IT.
>> CAN I INTERRUPT YOU.
>> Sean: THEY OBSTRUCTED, THEY
DIDN'T REPORT IT.
>> THEY DIDN'T GET IT WRONG.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT RIGHT OR
WRONG.
THEY'RE DRIVEN BY IDEOLOGY.
WHEN YOU'RE DRIVEN BY IDEOLOGY.
>> Sean: THEY REPORTED IT WRONG.
>> PURPOSEFULLY.
THEY WANT TO TAKE THE PRESIDENT
OUT.
THEY DECIDE WHAT'S IN THE NEWS,
WHAT'S LEFT OUT OF THE NEWS.
THAT'S WHY FOR THEM THERE'S A
RED LINE, A ALL OF THE ISSUES
INVOLVING THE DOSSIER, ALL OF
THE ISSUES INVOLVING SPYING.
THEY DISMISS THEM, THEY DISMISS
THE PEOPLE WHO SPEAK ABOUT IT.
THEY DISMISS THE WORDS.
THIS IS AN ID LOGICALLY DRIVEN
PROCESS.
LET ME GIVE YOU A STORY, GIVE
YOU HISTORICAL CONTEXT ON
CHAPTER 6.
THE HOLOCAUST.
6 MILLION JEWS ARE SLAUGHTERED.
OTHERS ARE SLAUGHTERED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" APPARENTLY
COVERED IT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BARELY
COVERED THE HOLOCAUST.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS OWNED BY
A JEWISH FAMILY.
IT BARELY COVERED THE HOLOCAUST
BECAUSE MR. SOLLACEBERGER
DECIDED HE DIDN'T WANT HIS
NEWSPAPER TO BE SEEN AS SORT OF
A JEWISH NEWSPAPER.
HE WANTED THE NEWSPAPER TO BE
MORE OF A UNIVERSAL NEWSPAPER.
FDR DIDN'T WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
HOLOCAUST.
SO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" COMPLY.
THEY WOULDN'T ACCEPT EVIDENCE
THAT WAS COMING, BEING PRINTED
IN EUROPEAN PUBLICATIONS.
THEY PRETENDED THE EVIDENCE WAS
NOT QUALITY EVIDENCE.
IT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
PEOPLE HAD ESCAPED, FIRSTHAND
ACCOUNTS, FOR THE MOST PART,
THEY IGNORED IT.
THREE SCHOLARS IN PARTICULAR
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE KNOW THAT "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" SELF-CENSORED
WHEN IT CAME TO THE HOLOCAUST
TEN YEARS BEFORE, WHEN STALIN
WAS SLAUGHTERING THE UKRAINIANS
AND SLAUGHTERING THEM TO DEATH,
THEY HAD A CORRESPONDENT IN
MOSCOW, THEY GOT A PULITZER
PRIZE FOR THE REPORTING, COVERED
UP WHAT STALIN HAD COMMITTED
AGAINST THE UKRAINE.
THIS IS "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
CAN ANY OTHER IN THE BUSINESS
SURVIVE THAT.
ALL OF THE NEWS FIT TO PRINT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STILL
HADN'T SIGNIFICANTLY AND
SERIOUSLY DEALT WITH THIS.
IT KEEPS THE PULITZER PRIZE.
TWO MASSIVE GENOCIDES IN THE
LAST CENTURY.
YOU DON'T FIND A LOT ABOUT IT IN
THE PAGES OF "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AT THE TIME.
THAT'S THE KIND OF MEDIA THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
BOOK SO GOOD.
YOU BRING IT FROM ITS HISTORY TO
MODERN DAY.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
GREAT ONE, MARK LEVINE ON